you should definitely be spending more
time indoors right now and you may even
have some more time on your hands to get
through that playstation pile of shame
here's a rundown of the 10 best rated
games for ps4
as gathered by review aggregator
metacritic
fyi we included some games that appeared
later on pc
and mobile but we did discount the ones
that appear on other home
consoles sorry xbox but if you'd like to
see an
xbox version of this list then make sure
to like this video and subscribe
kicking off the list with an old sega
classic res
infinite an on-rails music shooter that
originally came out in 2001
but was expanded and improved for
playstation 4.
res infinite is a technicolor marvel
hurtling you through cyberspace as you
shoot through a world of color and
music if you want to turn the intensity
down just a notch
you can even head into the new area x to
create music of your very own
if you own a psvr headset you owe it to
yourself
to try res infinite it might be
surprising to see not one
but two vr games in this list but really
it's a testament to sony's gamble on
affordable console based vr
paying off in at number nine is the
adorable astro bot rescue mission
which is sitting pretty with a meta
score of 90. not only is it a great
implementation of vr where the camera is
controlled by your head
but rescue bot is also a wonderful
platformer in its own right
featuring the absolutely adorable astro
bot
you may think that shadow of the
colossus is cheating a bit as the game
was originally made for the playstation
2 by team
ico but that would completely undermine
the incredible work done by blue point
games
in recreating the game for playstation
4. they managed to capture the haunting
spirit of the original game as well as
modernize it for a whole new audience
not only did they remake the assets so
the game would look
better but they also reconfigured the
controls to make them more in line with
what a modern audience would expect
there's a reason that shadow of the
colossus is as iconic today
as it was when it was first released so
if it passed you by
there's never been a better time to try
it out
oh i know i know you think now to tell
me that bloodborne is too
intimidating to play you've heard that
it's tough
and it's put you off well let me be the
one to tell you that if you can push
through that mindset
you'll experience one of the absolute
best games in playstation
history no other developer empowers
players through trial and error as well
as from software and bloodborne
is in my eyes their best work by
removing shields from the equation
indeed even going so far as to put a
terrible one in the game as a joke
fromsoft forced players to get up close
and personal
with the foul beasts of yanum again and
again
until their prey was slaughtered quite
thrilling
we would be remiss not to include
journey on this list
yes it came out on playstation 3 but was
also re-released for playstation 4.
it's not just one of the best
playstation games of all time
it's one of the best games of all time
period
we gave it our game of the year award in
2012.
through simple mechanics gorgeous
visuals and achingly beautiful music
it manages to deliver one of the best
video game experiences
you'll ever have it sounds like
hyperbole but
try it it's a beautiful serene
experience
from start to finish fair warning this
won't be the last time you see
a game by naughty dog on this list after
being the poster boy for the playstation
3
fans couldn't wait to see nathan drake
in a new adventure on ps4
a thief's end does what uncharted does
best
mixing bombastic action set pieces wise
cracks and treasure hunting
making nathan drake's ps4 adventure
easily his best
gamespot awarded it an elusive 10 out of
10 specifically calling out the
narrative that naughty dog had built in
the game
making nate feel less like a bullet
hungry action hero
and way more like an actual human being
i bet you didn't expect to see another
naughty dog game quite so soon but seven
years after the launch of the original
game which is oft cited as one of the
best games of all time
we finally got a sequel to the last of
us
set five years after the original game
ellie is on a relentless journey to
deliver justice to those who have
wronged her
and the quiet life she has managed to
build bigger and more brutal in every
way the last of us part 2 will likely go
down in history
as one of the playstation 4's swan song
titles
at number three is god of four sorry
war kratos had long been a playstation
icon for his blades of chaos and love
of smacking up some greek gods no one
expected a more nuanced take on the
character when the series arrived on ps4
in 2018.
the angry demi-god had left the greek
gods and their squabbles behind
and made a new life for himself in the
norse realms
where he had a wife and boy
to care for replacing the iconic blades
for an axe that you could throw and
would then return to you at the touch of
a button and adding in an emotional
story packed to the brim with action set
pieces
made god of war a remarkable and
brilliant reimagining
of the franchise a real show of force
from naughty dog on this list grabbing
the number two spot with the last of us
remastered
yes technically cheating because the
last of us originally released on
playstation 3 a year prior
but remastered did make meaningful
changes to an already incredible game
adding dualshock 4 integration a photo
mode
improved graphics and even developer
commentaries
the remastered package also threw in the
left behind dlc
which artfully examined ellie's
relationship with riley
joel and ellie's journey across a
post-pandemic america is as
heartbreaking as it is
tense and the game is considered by many
to elevate what video games can be
do yourself a favor and play it
in at number one is persona 5 royal
funnily enough persona 5 actually would
have appeared on this list
twice but we made an executive decision
not to include the base version of the
game in favor of
royal which is the definitive version
royal takes an already incredible
turn-based rpg social simulator
and improves upon it in so many ways
adding a new semester at shoojin academy
dungeon as well as characters story
elements and
gameplay tweaks to make an already
stunning battle system
sing let's do this senpai
[Music]
the enemy readings have decreased that's
gamespot awarded it 10 out of 10 with
reviewer michael hyam calling the game
a collection of small inspiring stories
an ambitious harrowing journey with some
good friends
a stunning visual and auditory
experience and a resounding call to
action
it's also absolutely worth checking out
the game's soundtrack which was recently
released on spotify
now if that doesn't get you to play it i
don't know what will
for deeper dives into some of the games
listed check out our episodes of audio
logs we did with the team at blue point
about shadow of the colossus
or with shigenori sojima about the
changes atlas made
to persona 5 royal and don't forget for
that xbox video make sure to like this
one
and subscribe to the channel i'm on
twitter at lucy james games
i'll catch you next time
you